all of my sexual fantasies involve
handcuffs
oh so wait wait wait are you
are you the one putting on the handcuffs
or are you or
are you handcuffed no to be clear i'm
always putting on the handcuffs oh
not this time pal
[Applause]
it's time once again for
how irredeemably stupid is the stupid
media it's totally irredeemably stupid
dude
why are you even asking greg
[Music]
lighten up voiceover guy so how
irredeemably stupid is the media
this irredeemably stupid you got lucky
tonight we're back with attorney michael
avenatti he is a main plate
to me you're like the holy spirit you
are all places
at all times he's out there saving the
country look i
think you're doing a hell of a job i
don't think you're in this for money
looking ahead to 2020
one reason why i'm taking you seriously
as a contender is because of your
presence on cable news
he's a rock star i think it'd be
interesting to see his next chapter
absolutely hey gail the title of the
next chapter
is in you're all stupid idiots
behold the naughty lawyer who
represented porn star stormy daniels in
legal battles with former president
trump sentenced to two and a half
years in prison a jury convicted
avenatti of trying to extort
up to 25 million dollars from nike and
this
is not the end of his legal troubles he
still faces
two more trials so there goes the
media's worst
presidential hopeful since hillary
yep a federal judge sentenced the
litigating lollipop to 30 months
a month for every selfie he took with a
cnn anchor
it's not quite three years which is
roughly the amount of time left in cat's
marriage
[Applause]
or kill meets hairline
and this for trying to extort millions
from nike he's headed to a federal
facility in oregon
a far cry from partying at don lemon's
place in the hamptons
although between those options i'd still
take oregon
but like many creepy exhibitionists
avenatti rose to fame on the back of
stormy daniels
yes but he really got a boost from the
drooling media
who saw him as their tinier hairless
version of trump
he was like a hopped up hamster
programmed to pontificate about that
evil orange godzilla
and it went according to plan for about
10 minutes
but now he's done he's ruined first
embraced and then spit out by the media
who adored him
but no longer want him around to remind
everyone else of their own idiocy
now you won't see him on cable unless
it's an episode of lock up
extended stay yes
he used the media they used him too
but you can bet that all those cnn
fanboys aren't answering his calls
anymore
except maybe stelter who is lonelier now
than he was at lunch
in the high school cafeteria so is it
wrong to take a victory lap
well it is my favorite form of cardio
and we're talking about the media here
who thinks you're stupid and that
they're always right on everything
and when they turn out to be wrong they
memory hole it faster than joe biden
being asked what he had for breakfast
fact is almost all the media's handiwork
is a hate crime hoax against you
they spend their careers making you into
the bad guy while elevating creeps like
avenatti
fueled by their own narcissism they
elevated him so they could look cool
overlooking the obvious red flags
everyone else could see
avenatti had more problems than a fox
and friends cooking segment
and and he makes cat look more wholesome
than a multi-grain breakfast cereal
yeah they took pictures with them they
partied with them and now they look like
tools
because they are tools his tools i
wonder if brian stelter will admit his
humiliation on reliable sources
because if he doesn't how can he be
considered reliable
just admit you screwed up captain cue
ball and be done with it
but you won't any more than rachel the
view or cuomo will
meanwhile before the court avenatti
cried like a newborn baby who just
slapped got slapped on his ass citing tv
and twitter
had evils that fueled his thirst for
fame he's right
he got to trend on twitter more times
than a kardashian butt pick
now he'll do his tweeting from cell
block c quenching his thirst with
homemade wine fermented behind a
radiator
so do you think any blue checks on
twitter or execs in cnn boardrooms care
about him
of course not they're running from him
like he's a cicada with corona
and what if that clucking clatter bag
anna navarro who compared him to the
holy spirit
now it's the father the son and the
please lose my number
will she visit this christ-like figure
in jail
or will she go the judas route and
pretend he no longer exists like she
does
with her principles but fox got his
number straight away
remember this golden moment you've
profited from stormy daniels
you've done tens of millions of dollars
worth of free media on the basis of your
relationship with her
and she's working in strip clubs you're
exploiting her
and you know that why aren't you paying
her some of what you're making sir this
is absurd but answer my question why are
you rich and your client is working
in cd strip clubs sir do you have any
idea how much money i've earned you're
on every cable show you're running for
president now i have no idea
i know that you haven't paid your taxes
and like so many lawyers you were taking
advantage of her
and you pose as a feminist hero because
you are shameless and the other channels
let you get away with it but you're an
exploiter of a woman and you should be
ashamed of it
wow
i think that was longer for avenatti
than the prison term
of course the view saw it differently
my takeaway was that avenatti came out
on top because that was tucker carlson's
show
that chiron on the bottom is calling him
a creepy porn lawyer
and you call yourself a television host
he's not exploiting the woman the woman
has got a book out
she's making money and this was her
profession he's blaming him
what was the phrase the pot calling the
kettle black
yeah no my father used to say people who
live in glass houses should dress
to dress in the cellar and my father
used to say
that joy behar makes no sense
meanwhile meanwhile after
embracing avenatti for so long
how is cnn covering avenatti now
look i never liked the guy terrible
total fraud
i never stood outside of his window at
night playing sexual healing out of a
boom box and i definitely didn't make
out with him in the hamptons
i never asked him to baptize my child
and i definitely didn't ask him for a
job in case he ran for president
but to me avenatti serves a purpose he
shows us how the media works and how it
does doesn't
and what it wants and what it will do to
get what it wants it wants ratings and
it hates threats to its ratings to its
influence or its power
they thought avenatti was the perfect
ally but it's like when kiss took off
their makeup
it all backfired so what do they do now
well if we know the media they'll
pretend like nothing happened the story
will vanish like joy reads homophobic
blog posts
because in the end they're all rats just
like avenatti
just with more places to hide
[Applause]
[Music]
he did stand up for 10 years till
someone realized you're perfect for a
job without laughter
fox and friends co-host brian kilmee
[Applause]
as a vegan she won't hurt animals but
people that's another story
fox business edward ankardigan mcdowell
his audiences shout requests like please
stop talking
comedian joe mackey
and she's at 10. but enough about her
blood alcohol content
fox news contributor cat tip
so brian you know you've been here for i
don't know 20 years you've made a lot of
mistakes
a lot i mean we've seen it's almost like
every week it's like a parade of errors
uh but you at least admit your errors
should the media that fond over this guy
apologize
can i look at the stat sheet you have a
lot of errors i mean
do you actually have even started 1998.
ability to accept and i agree with you
about the cooking segments by the way uh
on fox and friends i i didn't even laugh
i nodded yes
along uh a couple of things about my by
the way this crowd of four thousand
sounds like they're eight
they're fantastic and the most important
they like you right you know what it is
that doesn't happen a lot every person
that came in got a free edible
right all right all right there's
definitely not a fox and friends cooking
segment handout because nothing like
that is ever
edible but let me just bring up uh
enough about nike being extorted in 25
million dollars a company that prefers
to be
from china right getting extorted by a
lawyer with no ethics is not a big story
what he did is what he did to his other
clients with
their paraplegic where he took money and
didn't and they had no
recourse to get the money back and the
award money didn't even know
how much they were awarded and then you
think about stormy daniels whether you
think she's a victim or not she's not
somebody
she depended on him she took he took
over three hundred thousand dollars from
this one yes
so tucker was right on literally right
on the money
74 appearances on cnn in 10 weeks
yeah 10 weeks that's unbelievable there
should be a huge apology
from anderson cooper and company right
do you think that'll come no
it won't because that's why i asked you
that question oh
you know um you didn't ask me that
question i think i did
let's roll it back let's stop the show
i think you just talked about my record
yes you know uh
degan i think it was me who said it says
something
that stormy daniels a porn star her
worst decision
was hiring avenatti
it was no i think you said that i i may
have said that i can't remember
everything i say
i i think either i said it or you said
it but either either way i said it
[Laughter]
dagon you're from the south yes so just
fill in all the insults and then go to
your answer
um i can tell you that everyone i grew
up with could have seen this skis bag
from satellite imagery
that's how i mean we can spot a phony
absolutely immediately
but the p these kind of like ass tacular
news hucksters on cnn they need michael
avenatti
or a michael avenatti they need someone
more repugnant than they are more odious
than they are so they
appear kind of sort of normal right this
is this is
their version of balance right it's like
if i'm sitting next to this sleaze deck
not you joe um
i kind of look like a human
you know cnn's new slogan better get a
bucket you know it is interesting their
legal expertise goes from avenatti to
jeffrey tubin
you know that's a great question who
would you rather be
jeffrey tubin or michael avenatti
because what i don't know that's it
maybe that's a not a good question
sleeve stack no i wasn't in 2024
he'll be out he could become a cnn he
could join the cnn lineup
right should do the elections what do
you think joe
uh you know i it's something i learned
very early on they say the
enemy of your enemy is your friend but
the enemy of your enemy can also be
your enemy i had a lot of enemies yes uh
but yeah where he went wrong was trying
to extort nike
that's like trying to extort jay joy
behar for having a joke that doesn't
work
they don't care about the reputation at
all right yeah
it's it's weird like you get a couple
compliments from brian stelter
and you're like you know what i think i
can extort nike
i i don't get how you get from a to b
there like some sort of narcissism
because i've been on cable news a lot
and i don't think i'm that great
no you haven't you haven't extorted
anybody no no old fellow
downtown well he's dead r.i.p
yes yes but you know they do have legal
libraries
uh that are available to prisoners so he
could still become a lawyer
uh or but he's got other he's looking at
more charges
yeah and this guy's looking it's going
to get worse for him believe it or not
and how unbelievable is it that we
haven't pointed out the bigger picture
he was hired so to speak to take on
trump
right he was going to take down trump so
it wasn't so much making them look bad
or good
we can't touch trump we got a guy that
can and what he got is michael cohen on
house arrest
right yes another cnn contributor
bottom line is joe here's how i look at
it we can't let people forget about
avenatti
because the media wants us to forget
about it because it's a reminder of
their incompetence he'll be on prison
pell websites
it didn't work for my m.c hammer pants
and junior high school work for cnn
you know i understand low expectations
like low self-esteem
you want to like trade down not up to
yourself feel better
but i gotta say i've never hooked up
with somebody that disgusting
and i've you know what i've been there
you know
prisoners no i can stay the same
well actually i was going to ask before
i go now that he's going to prison is he
more attractive to you
before my husband yeah convicts are high
yeah that was always in the plus
and it was like has he done time is he
currently serving time
all right hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else